hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
so today trailer has just been released
for a little movie that I am really
looking forward to Tomorrowland Pirates
of the Caribbean now we have
Tomorrowland wasn't there another one
Oh a haunted house mansion the Haunted
Mansion the Eddie Murphy one before we
hop into the trailer and react and
review it I wanted to actually do
something that I normally save for the
end of videos I wanted to give a few
shoutouts really fast though sure cuz I
got a few big important messages that I
was like you know what for my knowledge
ease people upfront when real rejects
first started going somewhere there's
three subscribers who were super
interactive prototype guy
Kanaya one two three four five who I
still see comment a lot to this day and
Myles Parkinson first subscriber I
really started getting to know it was
his birthday on March 5th so I wanted to
say happy birthday to you sorry for this
thing going a little bit late he's 24
now and Parkinson's disease jokes no you
don't do that okay I'm sure he's gotten
away z al Oberon tests please read
hey real rejects I wanted to contact you
guys personally I've been going through
a lot in life I've been diagnosed with
something called muscular disc what is
that dystrophy dystrophy I'm smart and
multi mini core disease basically it
deteriorates my muscles oh Jesus yeah
you've read this no not yet girls
problems in so much more the past years
one thing that keeps me happy as well
movies okay okay I feel I feel a good
thing coming here I have a strong
passion for them in YouTube as well yes
okay I love your channel oh thank god
and your humor and all makes me laugh
and spa thank you thank you thank you
makes me you and Alyssa eight my
favorites Oh
like my dad I'm not asking for a
shout-out but one from both you would be
probably amazing this is not Alyssa I
got the I got the next best thing on the
list you know that's kind of that
reaction oh I love you guys and I doubt
you would read this [ __ ] look where
we are now but thank you guys for
keeping my head up you inspire me to
even make a channel if my own someday
thanks rejects for everything all over
Ron test
dude that is heartwarming that is
touching so no jokes I would avoid it
yeah I mean this is a very heartfelt I
don't think I mean it just make light of
it well you know he said were funny so I
thought well I mean there's a joke here
about understand muscular dystrophy and
many-core disease Multi many-core
disease maybe you should read up before
my age what if I was like really fat
girls cause my penis to have multi mini
cordis I'm gonna go with no all right
we're not doing no we're not doing it
but alo thank you so much that was very
sweet of you and start your own channel
vlog while you're in the hospital that
would be an interesting Channel yeah you
get a lot of followers girl problems
will be solved trust me once you like
get past a thousand followers on YouTube
women just line up left and right to
suck your dick so yeah don't you
remember those days we were
up-and-coming and then everywhere we
went they were like holy [ __ ] that's
Brian and Jerry from real rejects that's
[ __ ] crazy and like a bunch of
[ __ ] but I was like no I'm waiting
for the right one and Veronica came
along that's exactly how I remember it
Batum yeah and to this day [ __ ] still
hit us up it's ridiculous Ella anyway
we're five minutes into this video now
Tomorrowland
here we go
every second that ticks by
the future
where there's a place a secret place
nothing's impossible
where'd you get this what you saw was a
place for the best and the brightest
people in the world came together and
actually changed
we've been looking for someone like you
for a very long time you worry
one way
they were coming so
other people he thinks you could fix
please tell me this is not my max we
wanted to see Tomorrowland yeah here it
comes
cinemas 20 seconds nothing about IMAX
there can we just take a moment to
establish how awesome that film looks
yeah you know looks [ __ ] fantastic it
looks like a pure joy ride you know fish
outta water Fantasyland like it's called
Tomorrowland and it looks like they're
really delivering on a Fantasyland yeah
yeah one and it sort of maintains that
aesthetic quality that tomorrow and it
doesn't have yeah of course I love
seeing what George Clooney's doing you
know like I've never seen him do a roll
like that grumpy old scientist man never
seen is still charming George II still
think he's like good look II know it's
like grumpy old scientist hermit guy but
also George Clooney
he's like George Clooney at like 5:00 in
the morning yeah this is still George
Clooney's games dick sucked at 5:00 in
the morning in real life kids if you're
watching this Tomorrowland trailer
review stay tuned for more of that you
know what was very impressive to me it
what I pointed this out before and the
other trailer was it was really
impressive to me like when she touches
the the bottom and then she's in
Tomorrowland whatever that shock it's
seamless like it looks it doesn't look
like green screen or anything like it's
very seamless it's in the same shot it's
very impressive and it seems simple and
easy to do but it's really not and same
thing would like when she's driving in
the car and she's riding passenger and
she's just going like Wonder Woman that
is pretty hard to pull off but now it
look really good but it does take some
doing and it's always those things that
you wouldn't even necessarily think
about that are often the hardest there's
all sorts of effects that you don't know
are there you know well when you have a
YouTube channel like the real rejects
after a while you begin to learn how to
use the Flex this is pretty much you
know state of the art title text none of
this is actually here iMovie imported
music we didn't record
same time you know they have been things
that you can do already houses in the
house he doesn't look like he's playing
a douchebag this time even though we
barely got any clothes from him but he's
the bad guy because she says did
something happen over here or something
bad yeah but maybe he's like the the
president of Tomorrowland and something
bad happened and he's trying to make it
right
oh so might not be as simple as long
another guy Dylan he could be the bad
guy but maybe he's not I'm just saying I
didn't get a clear sense of that
officially because later on the trailer
they're like together and it doesn't
look like they're not friendly Brad Bird
is just gonna do you know like he's the
perfect director for a film like
Tomorrowland well yeah and he's got a
great track record always a little bit
nervous you know the bigger the projects
get but he he really does seem like one
of the directors you can count on to
really turn in something that's really
visually interesting and and you know
really well assembled and he's very
selective with the films he chooses yeah
he doesn't make a film every year people
been wanting in Incredibles to for the
longest time is like maybe an idea and
then he got a bunch of offers for other
things after Ghost Protocol and ghost
Protocol he's got another live-action
[ __ ] offers mmm that's the word
offering think offering offering like
Church offering I start to wonder like
is he ever gonna go back to animation or
when would he go back to animation
because like up until ghost Protocol
most of what we know and before his
animated features and it and shows and
what's great about it is he does bring
that level of imagination to these
movies but he doesn't overdo it with the
humans where it's cartoony it's cool
that he applies his level of imagination
he's put into animation that rhymes all
surrounds the direction you're a poet
and you weren't even aware until you
pointed it out just now huh yeah it
seems like he's really good at making
movies that fit together it's like you
know they're imaginative and they're
sort of big but everything fits that
world and stuff like that cuz Ghost
Protocol is like everything is kind of
the right size you know and I think what
really captured the Incredibles really
well was his level of humanity he
brought to this this animated superhero
film like they were
very relatable humans who weren't going
through tough times
ghost Protocol was an action-adventure
flick maybe not the biggest on character
but I feel like he probably like this is
gonna apply a lot more character to this
one because I'm sure he had more
creative control
maybe Disney it seems like Disney
probably has a good amount of trust for
him and he's got a good track record
anyway yeah so I think he knows probably
how to work with them he's got a good
driving record too sure he doesn't have
great driver he's won a ticket right
driver doesn't seem like a guy to have a
lot of tickets yeah he once did kill
someone in a drunk right don't
perpetrate this alright hey if you guys
are new to the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects I feel I actually
feel kind of bad about that one yeah
don't don't even start that I'm just
trying to piss people off and Jerry has
a playlist on this channel called the
reasons to Jerry I call it the reasons
to Jerry they're definitive yep we have
an instagram twitter and facebook check
us out there and i don't know what the
[ __ ] else do we say to promote ourselves
just you know come to Ryan's house show
huh actually no no you can you can come
to ride and like thinking around yeah
that'll help somehow we talked my
releases endorphins oxytocin starts
spray to that [ __ ] brain and then
they'd be developing an emotional
attachment towards me because they've
been thinking about me sexually at least
the woman on this channel the 16%
demographic of woman we have on the 16%
yeah it's 84% man very dude humor my
hammer is more attuned to women men are
so dumb all they care about is sex sex
sex sex
that's all they want they want me to
blow them lick their [ __ ] and then
strap on a dildo and [ __ ] them because
it's it's true observational comedy
small group I guess you know no comedy
comedy makes me laugh it makes me laugh
some comedy
but day yeah you know cuz it didn't
quite hit the comedy right you know what
also wasn't funny like no humor at all
Passion of the Christ